would you say that one of the big
symptoms of a relationship that needs
attention and work and communication is
um
sex or lack of
um I think sex is important to a
relationship but not every person values
it the same so it depends on the couple
so not everyone values
sex the same way and it can become
difficult if you're in a relationship
with someone who values it very high and
you value it very low that's very
difficult but you know values do need to
be aligned so not everyone not everyone
values sucks I mean there's some couples
that are very happy having sex once a
month or once a week and there are some
who are like no I need to do it multiple
times a week these are one of the
difficult conversations that couples
need to have is is that if you're in a
relationship and it's important to you
to have something Beyond just
companionship
then be keeping chemistry alive and
attraction alive and your sex lives
Alive is is important and takes
attention what what are what are the
best ways to do that the least sexy
thing is being stressed out all the time
that's not when we're hot is when we're
stressed so if we're chronically
stressed what's happening are we not
giving to ourselves are we not filling
our cup are we not exercising are we not
resting are we not talking to someone so
we have to take care of our emotional
mental well-being that's very very
important because when we do
we're more energized and when we're
energized we bring that energy to a
relationship and it's sexy
also having passion outside of the
relationship like the hottest thing is
seeing the person that you're into that
you're in a relationship with in their
element it could be like I was talking
to my friend she's like I'm most
attracted to my husband when we're
traveling because that's when he's like
he's really a great traveler he takes
control he speaks multiple languages
they travel overseas so he's just like
he just moves through the Nuance of
international travel so gracefully and
she's like that's when he's hottest to
me you're doing things that are
enhancing that that you get to see that
you know and I think every couple and
it's different for every single one but
every couple has to navigate
the dance between togetherness and
separateness
time together but also time apart
and it has to work for both people yeah
and I think that that's a big part of
compatibility actually is that unspoken
agreement about what feels how much how
amount of time feels apart feels good
like it makes the heart grow fonder
versus not
I saw on Instagram it was
um John gottman talking about
that the things that worked 50 years ago
in a relationship are really the a lot
of the same things that still work today
I feel like the landscape of
relationships is getting tested and
challenged
um you know we look at like open
relationships or polyamory or
Hollywood I don't know there's just like
so many there's so many phrases Words
letters names
so what is it that is like the
fundamentals and what is it that still
works and what do you see maybe changing
and being part of the future of
relationships that's going to be a good
add-in that's new we put so much stock
on in romantic relationships now it's
like I need you to be my soul mate
like people 50 years ago weren't looking
for a soul mate yeah you know and it's
like I need you to be my best friend my
Confidant my this and that and
I think we just put so much stock in
romantic relationships and really we
need to have multiple sources of Love
around us
so that would be one thing change that I
think that you know we have to adapt to
a little bit but also the pitfall is
that now people are like searching for
the one and they want this person
perfect person to check all the boxes
and meet all their needs it's impossible
to meet each other's needs all the time
the basics I mean the basics is just be
kind to each other
the basics is communication
the basics is listen to one another the
basics is have quality time together you
know for some people raise a family
together accepting each other
fundamentally for who you for who the
other person is when you look at really
successful relationships and and I
measure successful relationships with
two people who really like each other
and love each other they're not perfect
but they really really like each other
and and they still want to have sex with
each other maybe not like it was in the
beginning that doesn't last forever but
they're still attracted and they really
just they laugh together they have a
good time together they they move
through they don't have a they have
challenges but they're not constantly in
a state of challenge
those people they are just really good
friends to each other and they accept
each other a hundred percent that
doesn't mean that they accept or
tolerate shitty Behavior no no but they
fundamentally they're like oh this is
your thing this is your weakness like
this is my weakness like I'm not judging
you for that I love you for that if I'm
gonna judge you for that then we're not
right for each other I said that we
always want our partner to be just like
us it's really a big problem because you
don't it's like it would be so boring we
have to celebrate the differences like
there has to be like you know you need
friction to create fire
so if you're just too much of the same
after a while you don't want to sleep
with too much of the same sure I think
gottman's even says that the amount of
friction there's like a perfect percent
there's there's a yeah a really
successful ratio for like good to bad
um uh communication but you have to
always understand that a real a
relationship is the sum of its parts so
it's like if a relationship's not going
well what are the two people in the
relationship not doing well and some
people and I've been there before so
it's not a judgment but it's something
that people need to be aware of and
reflect on and that is some people they
have a really bad habit of just being
critical
or they have a really bad habit of
wanting to control or they have a really
bad habit of whatever it is the more I
judge myself the more I judge someone
else yes 100 it's not like it's just
such a reflection like more like I used
to judge people for being lazy a lot
because because you're a perfectionist
and I would never sit around and so the
more I give myself permission to rest
the more I now look at someone resting
instead of being lazy right
like it always seems like it just comes
back to the self yes and that would be
sort of like the shadow work like the
things that really trigger us and
someone else is the thing that we are so
divorced from in our lives and the funny
thing about relationships is that the
super type let's say the super type A
personality might be attracted to the
really easy going go with the flow
person because they have something in
them that they wish they had inside
themselves or maybe it is inside
themselves but they've repressed it and
so they're attracted to that but if you
don't actually acknowledge it in
yourself if you don't actually then rest
then you're just constantly going to see
that then then that go with the flow
person that you were so attracted to in
the beginning now it becomes like the
thorn on your side but if you can then
learn how to go with the flow if you can
learn how to rest then you can
appreciate more what this person brings
to the relationship we live a lot longer
so our relationships really supposed to
last a lifetime I don't know probably
not
I think it depends what at what point in
your life you begin the relationship is
there a reframe just needed for
relationships ending instead of calling
them failing because as we grow and
evolve it can be beautiful to just it's
always beautiful when you grow and
evolve in a positive way
there's no guarantee that's going to be
with that person and but we look at
every time a relationship ends and we
look at like what's wrong with me we're
in a day and age where people are going
to start to live to 120 I know it's kind
of nuts right
um look there are lots of people who
stay together for 50 years and they're
miserable I mean I see that as a bigger
failure why well because why is that a
success just because you lasted you were
miserable in making each other miserable
so the failure is not saying yes to
yourself and your own happiness yeah
well I mean but that's a slippery for
being honest
there are people who give
up long and the only thing you can do is
know what your pattern is some really
some people come into our lives and
they're meant to wake us up some people
come into our lives and they're meant to
just like get us through a difficult
part in our life some people come into
our lives and they're just meant to be
like you know they're just meant to be a
chapter not many and that doesn't mean
that because it ended that's a failure I
think that the hardest thing is hanging
on to people who really so clearly are
just meant to be a chapter and it's very
hard look love is a is very irrational
something a little while back a couple
months ago that maybe I read it watched
it that
chemistry is actually a symptom of a
trauma
and I'm like I am gonna stay in trauma
forever then yes no I don't agree no way
I'm stepping into a relationship where
I'm not really feeling it but like you
know they're not I don't get that
statement at all thank God tell me why
tell everyone why chemistry is important
well first of all chemistry is mostly is
is is hormones and neurotransmitters
that's basically what it is it's it it's
smell it's pheromones it's what not now
if
your pattern is to only be attracted to
people who abuse you
in one form or another
your the chemistry that you're having
with people is a result of your trauma
if you're only having chemistry with
people who don't abuse you but it ends
up just not being right
well you have to it's your Chemistry not
is is not necessarily due to trauma but
it needs to be matured
um it's like your chemistry is off so
you're attracting the wrong thing so
you're being a TR you're attracted to
the wrong P thing so in other words it's
like okay well I said women are
attracted to strength and so we're
talking heteronormatively right now but
I I I also know a lot of gay women who
are attracted to strength but let's just
stick with this so women are attracted
to strength let's stick with the woman
and the man because this is what I see
the most is an example that I'm about to
share when it comes to chemistry oh you
know he's got broad shoulders he's got a
good job you know he's got a little bit
of an edge a little bit of a bad boy
Edge he's strong I'm attracted but what
she needs to see is that you want to be
attracted to mental strength
and someone who can actually not just
the mental strength emotional strength
someone who will protect you and that's
very important you don't know that until
you actually get to know someone how
many times have you seen walking down
the street and absolutely stunningly
beautiful model level like amazing
looking woman with a man who's really
unattractive and people will say we're
really more common that direction yeah
it's more common in that direction than
the other way right why well she's a
gold digger no she feels safe with that
man
if you like this clip and you want to
hear the whole episode click at the
bottom of your screen